بل حتى انه جعل من
المستشفيات اهدافا رئيسيه معلنه لعملياته
البريه
والميدانيه فيعلن عمليه عسكريه تستهدف
مستشفى الشفاء ثم المستشفى
الاندونيسي وهكذا بقيه المستشفيات
يعلنها اهدافا عسكريه وكانها قواعد
عسكريه في تصرف سلوك لا سابقه له بهذا
الشكل الدول والاقوام والاتجاهات التي
تتحارب
عاده ما تعلن القواعد العسكريه او المواقع
الاستراتيجيه او اهداف ذات اهميه عسكريه
اهدافا لها في الحرب والعمليات العسكريه
اما العدو الاسرائيلي فهو يعلن بكل
وقاحه يعلن المستشفى هدفا لعمليته
العسكريه ويقتل ويدمر وحينما يصل الى الى
المستشفى يستهدف الجرحى ويستهدف المرضى
ويستهدف الكوادر الطبيه والممرضات ويستهدف
من هناك من المدنيين بكل اجرام وبكل
وحشيه ثم يقدم ذلك انجازا
عسكريا ويتباهى به فهو
بجرائمه الشنيعه والواضح جدا
والمكشوفه